hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca I'm fornicates here gonna
be talking about the new infernal so
many of us could be shown some gameplay
of it seeing how all of it works out and
all that good stuff just showing you
some of what you're in store for if you
happen to do play this new event mode
now there's a few changes from the
regular Dominion the changes are is that
there's going to be four points if you
boost an objective instead of two you
cannot heal on any of the objectives
minions do not give points anymore they
now are the your only source of health
if you want to gain any more back since
there are no feats as well and there's
gonna be fire around of the objectives
if contested and there's a lot more
which I'll explain once we get into the
video and all that stuff like that full
details on everything in this mode into
the entire event you can click the video
and the top right to learn all about
that from my previous video like I said
which has all the details of just this
mode and the entire event in general so
you're caught up to date with everything
with that let's get into some infernal
Dominion gameplay now we are finally in
the game I believe we're playing on
overwatch there are two samurai maps and
one night map that have got changed with
this little fire effect so not all of
them are going to be fully engulfed in
flames and stuff like that there's only
gonna be three which sucks because I
don't know what the vikings didn't get
any it's really confusing why they
didn't but either way as you can tell
since then the thing is now contested
where you got the flames around it the
flames do a lot of damage they do about
two bars the health at least for
gladiator I'm not entirely sure how that
would incorporate some other characters
but that only happens when the objective
is contested so if two people happen to
art like I said if it's just a normal
objective and no one's capped it and
stuff like that then it's not gonna
happen but it's only when it's contested
the teammate here just got a buff it's
the only buff throughout the entire map
it's actually a fire booster buff I
forgot to mention the beginning this
gives you a twenty percent speed boost
does flame damage on the opponent now
kind of like the fire bow but it's now
for all your attacks and the flames that
you'll be seeing up in a second during
the contested area you can walk right
through those with no repercussion
whatsoever which is really nice good
parry on the shaman as you can see that
my buddy can't just walked right through
those flame it's no repercussions at all
just because he has that buff on he
could have walked in probably taking a
little bit of damage but he doesn't
really care since he has that buff on I
do have a little bit of less health than
I'd started with so once I finished this
Orochi or hopefully or my teammate can
say where's completely with the plunge
attack I can go kill some minions
because
it's my only source of helpfulness mobic
I've stated I can't say definitely needs
that or he's gonna get killed hard got a
conk teammate to help us out here three
hundred to five five hundred to five
again a pretty its start you know pretty
good start of the game depending on how
long this goes I might do one or two I
don't know how long this Dominion
specific Dominion match we've got we'll
see how long it goes now see it's
contested but I can still walk through
it I just have to take a hefty chunk of
damage which is going to you know make
this just a little bit harder for me to
defend myself but I also get to help my
teammate fell for that shaman thing
again I got to stop that compari on that
on the shinobi here little on stamina so
I'm gonna pull back of it hopefully that
conk doesn't need me oh we let it rip
this time I have the side bash heavy
good stuff
there's no change on respawns or
anything like that so that is still
gonna stay the same just like normal
Dominion just the few changes that I've
mentioned throughout this video have
changed and the map by the way just
looks incredibly beautiful with a lot of
fire everywhere and there's the volcano
in the background behind this la bring
your teammate by see that's just a rough
thing with volcano will fire blasts and
like everything is going haywire in this
map I also put on the new mask outfit
since I just thought it would you know
fit the theme and all that stuff sinchon
you know I just feel you know we're in
the new event new mask might as well put
it on and hopefully this'll all bring
her teammate it seems to be net big
right
Oh cancer is coming in oh now he's got
it
his teammate ah damn I was gonna do the
effect I was gonna do the new uh I was
gonna show off the little mask effects
for the execution but I got my execution
stolen that's a shame but the idol if it
looks really cool especially for the
night's not member this is faction base
so the Knights one is not going to be
the one that the Vikings the samurai get
they're a little bit of a different
variation but it's still a demon mask so
either way it still looks really damn
cool oh I'm gonna go to see here see how
we do it this one
no one's capped so far that's good I'm
gonna stay here hopefully we can keep it
like this and I can test it later he's
done now the contest had the fire buff
again I believe the fire buff lasts for
about 30 to 40 seconds according to the
developers and a lot of light spam and
then I believe after it goes away I
think it comes right back so you could
technically farm it if you really wanted
to don't have to the I'm gonna do the
execution gonna choke to air it out did
the wrong one I thought this was the
choking one either way I'll just knock
out shaman she deserves anyway still
really cool I like how the character
lights up in red but I definitely like
the mask portion this to blue looks
really devilish no I'm going off the map
damn I dodged a little bit too early for
that scent I was gonna tell that he was
near a Ledge one to push him off and did
not happen it's [ __ ] not doing too well
against the shinobi impressed
you have every objective so like this
seems to be a pretty quick match
as you can see in the top right it says
that seeing a are both one point but as
soon as I hop on the boost for C it's
now four so this is actually a lot of
points you definitely want to be sitting
on these objectives most of the game if
you are trying to win this mode and
stuff like that you definitely want to
be sitting on this defending it when it
comes by and then if you're low on
health just go in the middle and kill
the minions come back I don't remember
exactly where the buff is on every map I
just know that on overwatch it's right
there by those stairs next to the
objective so if you happen to be home
and I just got [ __ ] killed by Orochi
I saw him drop down I wanted to stop and
hopefully dodge that but you know I was
good on him so now don't have that buff
anymore but yeah it's kind of a rinse
and repeat staying that objective boost
it then do some then if you're low on
health kill the minions come back stuff
like that this is a really fun game but
let me know in the comments if you guys
think that this is a really cool mode I
think it's definitely one of my favorite
events it's not my favorite event but
it's definitely a second best I think
test your mettle still wins in best
event we're gonna cap this here get some
more points we're slowly we're barely
winning so we're gonna come back get
some points boost this for a bit team
seems to be in a 2v2 situation 2v1
situation okay I'll sit here and do my
civil duties of dodging or dodging the
shinobi hopefully doesn't kill me gotcha
buddy get lost now auger parry probably
could've uh probably gonna throw him off
but wanted to get that heavy attack in
anyway this is I knew he's gonna let him
fall here to boost this for a bit until
we hit a thousand or the shamans just
like not what do you what do you mean a
thousand [ __ ] off and I'll just knock
her off the map that's that counts well
bring her slowly waiting for the fire to
come out it's not good dude Open Sesame
I'm gonna go down while he boosts that
for a bit so I can grab some kill some
minions get some quick help
are you doing and also the minions do a
slight bit of damage nothing too crazy
like in terms of breach or the other
minions for the past events we've had
where they do crazy damage but it's
nothing like this nothing like the
original minions so they do they look
slightly in the middle nothing too crazy
though I really haven't even notice the
damage but yeah I managed to kill half
this team just by alleging them because
I'm an absolute scumbag and good fights
ba guys it's going to be the end of the
v-j hopefully you guys did enjoy that
just wanted to show it just a little bit
of the gameplay of the new mode and
stuff like that cuz honestly I think
this is a really cool game what
definitely be playing this a lot more
now I just also just trying to get the
gear as well but might as well have
something to enjoy myself with and you
could play this in PvP and in P Vai so
either way it's a tough up to you the
way you want to play this but yeah like
the view if you do enjoy subscribe
graffiti I cover the informational side
of foreign or most of the time that
being balance changes hero updates leaks
patch notes like I said before all that
good stuff as well doing some gladiator
gameplay and stuff like that and some
new gameplay on the upcoming characters
when they happen to release in October
oh yeah my two most juicy videos will be
on screen if you guys are gonna check
that out that guy's great yesterday take
fortune video
[Music]